so if you're broke or you don't know
what business to start by the end of
this video you will know what business
to start who you're going to serve how
you're going to serve them and the exact
message to send to get your first five
customers I'm a co-owner of school.com
where we help tens of thousands of new
people every single month start their
first business online and right now one
out of two people who start a paid
community on school make their first
dollar one out of two this process I'm
going to show you works so there's five
parts of this Frameworks and then two
bonuses one is that's a advance and one
that'll give you next steps on what to
do with this so you can make your first
dollar so it starts with the what which
is what is your business actually going
to be about and so I use something
called the three PS framework all right
so you can write this down the three PS
and that's because almost all businesses
get born of one of these three PS the
first is pain so it's something that you
went through personally and had to
overcome so A friend of mine has a wife
well they're married and they have nine
kids and so in her going through this
process she was like well what would
work for me and I'm like well you have
nine kids so I'll bet you that you just
making lunch for nine kids every day is
probably a process she's like oh yeah I
have this whole thing that I do so I
organizes so everybody has their own uh
bags and they all know who it is and
then I can do it in a time that's cheap
for me and gets them all the food that
you know all the protein and all the
other stuff in the Street's like I have
a system around that and I was like that
is the beginning of a business the
second is your profession meaning what
you do for a day job or what you've done
in the past I've recently made a video
about a lady who quit her job as a
registered dietitian at a hospital and
then started teaching other registered
dietitians how to Bill insurance and the
reason that she learned how to do that
was at the hospital she had to work six
days a week and work 12 plus hours per
day as an RD and so she only had one day
a week that she could bill her personal
clients on the side and so she had to
figure out this really complex Billing
System and how to do it really quickly
and so she took something that she
learned from her profession and made a
business around something really really
narrow and so a lot of people think that
it's got to be this big crazy thing if
you solve one very specific problem for
somebody that is a business and you
might think oh well how am I going to
get a huge following from all that this
particular individual has 5,800 people
who follow on Instagram and she takes
home almost a million dollars a year in
income and so if you're an accountant or
you do HR or you edit videos or you do
whatever like every single job that
exists in a business means that
fundamentally people exchange money for
the skill you have and so any
professional skill that you do in a
business you can do as a consultant or
as an independent contractor or teaching
other people in that profession there's
lots of tree branches that come off of
that but this is the second big category
that businesses are born from the third
bucket of peas is Passion these are the
things that you're always interested in
these are the Articles you read these
are the YouTube videos you watch these
are the podcasts that you listen to in
your spare time it's the stuff that
you're just inherently interested in
that you like can't get enough of and so
for me personally I was somebody who was
into fitness it was what I was reading I
was reading tenation which none of you
guys have even heard of but it was this
blog online that had all of the lifters
in there and all these trainers and
coaches that were talk about stuff and
every night I would eat my meal and I
would read whatever the new T Nation
articles were and I did that every
single night and that's what my passion
was and when I went to work the guys
that I worked with are like dude if you
don't start a gym like I will they like
they offered to front me the money to
start the gym because I was so obsessed
with Fitness at the time and so if
you're like okay well I overcame food
allergies or I am an accountant or I'm
into painting model cars got it but how
am I going to turn that into a business
don't worry that's what I'm covering in
step five so let me break this belief
for you really quickly that you need to
get the perfect pick on the first try
the reason this isn't accurate is that
it assumes that
you with zero context having not talked
to customers and gotten zero feedback or
are going to pick it right the reality
of it is that picking anything is the
first step because that begins the
iteration process of feedback so that
you can get it right so the five-step
process I'm going to walk you through is
going to get you to your best bad idea
as fast as possible and the reason we
say best bad idea is that we want to get
it out there so that we can make it less
wrong over time and if you keep making a
bad idea less wrong eventually it
becomes a good idea and then people say
how did you pick that right on the first
shot and you will smile and know that
that's not actually how it worked so
great if you have your first P you say I
know what pain it is or what profession
or what passion Now we move on to step
two which is the who so who are you
going to do this what for there's three
categories that the who's are going to
fit into the first is people like you
the second is people that you've helped
before and that can be for money or not
for money but I'm assuming if you're
watching this video that you haven't
helped them for money you just did it as
a favor which I'll tell you my story
about that in a second and the third is
people who you think are underserved now
this is probably the more formal way
that people look at markets that are
growing that you think there's an
emerging Trend it's people that have
this huge demand and they're underserved
this is probably the most formal way of
doing it but most businesses that come
from I would say the heart or the mind
come from one of these two things it's I
went through this thing and then I took
a long time to figure it out and now
that I had fig F out I want to help
other people who are like me figure it
out Sarah Blakeley was like man none of
these underwear like you know hide the
hide the bad and show the good and so
then she created Spanx and then Spanx
went on to sell for a billion dollars to
blackon I think earlier last year and so
you can absolutely build a massive
business just trying to solve a very
personal problem to yourself differently
Zuck started in his dorm room to make
some sort of platform for horny college
kids that eventually would become face
Facebook or for me specifically the
reason I made my first dollar the first
actual dollar that I ever made was there
was a lady at the gym and she said she
came to me and said hey can you help me
with my food and it was just cuz I
looked in shape and I was like sure and
like I didn't know her super well and so
we met at a pizza shop ironically and
she and so she asked me to talk to her
about her food and so I just asked her
what she was buying for her groceries
and gave her a couple of you know
recipes that I did to increase her
protein intake and at the end of me
sitting at that pizza parlor with her
for like an hour and a half she just
took out her purse and wrote on a check
$100 and she handed it to me I didn't
sell her I didn't say a price she just
handed me $100 for the amount of help
that I'd given her and it was really
weird because we walked out of the pizza
parlor and then she got in her car and I
like opened up the check again and I was
like holy I could get paid to do
this and it was this huge moment for me
and forever always grateful Sandy Smith
so once you figured out whether it's
someone like you someone you've helped
before or an underserved Market you pick
one of these three things and then you
plug them into this which is a call out
and so the call out describes the person
back to them this is going to be
important for what we use in one of the
later parts of this that's why if I had
to pick one for you I would have it be
this one because you already know what
it's like to have the Pains of this
person you're usually in the demographic
you have you're in the age group and so
you probably know a lot of the
aspirations and dreams that they do
rather than having do the research so
this is the quick and dirty way and many
many many businesses are started this
way and in my
opinion this tends to make mercenaries
this tends to make missionaries and so
what I mean by that is people who start
purely based on analyzing markets and
Trends and things like that they're like
they're in it for the money they don't
really care about the product or even
the customer but if you're helping
people like you overcome something that
you overcame before you know their pain
and you will care that much more to
deliver an exceptional product and
improve their experience over time and I
think this is what keeps you in it for
the LA ha and when you look at some of
the biggest companies out there in the
world many of them started with a
Founder in a garage with some problem
that they hated and then tried to fix so
let me draw this on a new page to give
you a really clear idea of why this next
part is important if you're just like
people like me that's not descriptive
enough to get really clear on the Avatar
and so I think about it as having five
kind of frames that I think through to
narrow down my avatar I've got the age
gender profession like before because if
you are going to use profession then you
might as well say it got their problems
or their pains and then we've got their
interests or passions and you'll notice
these are more or less than three PS
from before okay and so what we do is
you want to
pick three and so let me give you an
example so if I'm looking for
35-year-old men to it's not narrow
enough right or if I just said 35-year
old it's not narrow enough 35-year-old
men who were accountants now I can get
even narrower by adding more but you
have to have at least Le three you want
to do three or more so 35-year-old male
accountants who uh are bored at their
jobs right great well that's a pretty
clear Avatar if I say that and there's a
room full of 35-year-old male
accountants who are aboard their
jobs and that was in the other room that
other room should light you up so think
about it this way from a visual
perspective if you could fill a room
with just a certain type of person that
You' get excited to go in there and help
them what is that room of people look
like what are they interested in what
are the problems they're suffering from
what what's their job now you could do
the same thing and not have the
profession but I'll give you an example
so if I said 35-year-old or 45-year old
women who are struggling to move up in
the
workplace okay that's at least three get
the idea so you just want to get narrow
enough that they know you're talking to
them let me break a second belief for
you that if you get really narrow it
means you're not going to be able to
make as much money because you don't
have as many people to sell to the other
part of that is the more specific you
get the more you can charge so let me
tell you something that might blow your
mind so if I sold time management as my
thing that's really really broad all
right that's my what okay well I might
be able to charge for my time management
PDF I don't know 19 bucks okay now if I
said I've got a time management product
for salese then all of a sudden this is
probably a $199 product if I said I have
time management for outbound salespeople
then that's going to be even more
specific and this might be a
1999 product and if I said I have the
entire outbound time management system
for garden and power tools then this
could be a $10,000 thing because anybody
who's this specific with their Niche
knows that they're going to be able to
make a couple sales with this new system
and more and pay for it and so as you
get more specific with your prospect you
can get more premium with your price and
if you're the best at time management s
for outbound sales rep that do garden
and power tools how many competitors are
you going against almost no one and so
you're selling in a total blue ocean
where it's just you with the with a life
raft and all of them are in there in the
pool around you struggling and then when
you have your lifecraft and you're the
only boat in town they've got to pay
whatever you want in order to to scoop
them out of the water if you're enjoying
this process I run something called the
school gam you can go to school.com
games you can start for free I'll help
you build your first business by taking
you through Frameworks like this and
many others and give you the platform to
do it to make your first dollar right
now more than one out of two people who
start the school games with a paid
Community make their first dollar online
very proud of it so if you like that go
check it out you can start for free so
that's step two that's the who now we go
to the how and there's two parts to the
how how so let's cover those now so with
how part one we think about the upside
this is all the good stuff that you're
going to help them achieve or experience
as a result of using your thing all
right so you want to think about how
much easier their lives are going to be
as a result of using your thing you want
to think about how guaranteed the
outcome is now as a result of using your
thing you want to think about much
faster they're going to be able to get
what they want using your thing and you
want to be able describe to them how it
would feel to experience their dream
scenario and so if these look familiar
these are the four elements of the value
equation but written in the positive and
so the perfect offer is something that
is incredibly easy guaranteed to happen
immediate and is exactly what they want
and the sub part of this is exactly the
way they want to get it I'll give you a
b a b example from gym launch so the
average gym makes $30,000 in their first
30 days you using the gym launch system
now the average gym owner makes $36,000
a year in take-home income so if they
make $36,000 a year as take-home income
then we can help them get what they want
easier guaranteed faster and exactly
what they wanted to do which was to fill
their gym up and make money whatever
benefits you sell there's some good
stuff and so we want to say hey here's
all this good stuff you want and here's
how I make it easier faster guaranteed
and this is what it looks like when it's
right that's what we explain with the
how part one so now that we've listed
out all the good stuff let's flip over
to how part two which is going to be the
bad stuff and if you think about
motivating an individual in general you
fundamentally only have two things that
are going to increase the likelihood
that they do what you want you either
have to take away the bad stuff that
they don't want or give them more good
stuff that they want that's it that's
all you can do and so thinking about it
from this framework has helped me so
much in copyrighting in sales it's like
you're either you're going to get this
thing or you're going to avoid this
thing you hate that's it and it's just
how well you can describe either of
these things which makes it more and
more compelling which is why picking
someone like you makes it easier to
describe the very intricacies of their
pain so for example if I said lose
weight fast that might have worked in
the 1900s but people quickly learn that
they can't believe things that people
say and so the more specific you are
about the pain and the benefit the more
likely they are to believe you if I say
hey stop feeling your thighs chafing
when you're out in the sun that's a very
specific pain right and so someone would
be like oh I I experienced that but it
would pass their guard rails and their
Banner blindness around ads and copy and
marketing because it's very specific to
their pain you want them to be like I
can't believe they know this about me
because you know it about you and you
just describe it back to them so now
we're going to talk about the bad
stuff so these are the inverse of the
things that I was mentioning earlier so
instead of the guarantee we're going to
talk about the risks that we're going to
help them avoid instead of how fast it
is we're going to talk about how slow it
is for them that they're not going to
have to experience that slowness instead
of it being easy we're going to talk
about all the pain and sacrifice and
suffering that they have to go through
in order to experience the benefit so
the nice thing with this one
particularly because there's going to be
the most meat here in terms of what
you're describing because the guarantee
you to say this is where you state stats
and you and you show what you've done
what you plan to do the fast and easy
you put a timeline around it and what
they can expect versus the timeline of
what's bad and with the ease there's two
sides to this so one is what are all the
good things they normally have to give
up that they no longer have to give up
with your system and what are all the
bad things that they would normally have
to start doing with other products or
other services to solve this problem
that with your product they don't have
to start doing so let me give you an
example so weight loss is simple so if I
have to start working out and waking up
early then that's something bad I don't
want to start doing and so if you use my
system you don't have to start doing
this bad thing you don't want to do to
get the result if I want to avoid the
negative thing that you don't want to
give up which is hey you like doing taco
Tuesdays and eating out with your
friends normally you'd have to give that
up but with my system you can keep that
thing you like without sacrificing it
and still get the result and so you show
both of these that make it easier
because what makes things hard what
makes things hard is doing things we
don't like and giving up things we like
and so if we have our solution that they
can not have to do things they hate and
keep doing things they love then they
will like that better you might be
thinking okay well I get the good stuff
and the bad stuff for how part one and
how part two but how do I get all this
stuff well first off if it's you then
you know what these pains are if it's
not you then you do the three-letter
method you ready for it ask people who
you want to sell so you get on the phone
you reach out to people and you
basically do an interview now a good
interview basically functions like a
sales call which is like what are the
problems you're struggling with right
now how long have you struggled with
them what makes it painful specifically
can you describe what the experience is
like when it's not right could you
describe your ideal experience if it
were done the right way what are some of
the things you have to stop doing that
you like doing that you don't want to
stop doing when you've done things in
the past what are the things that you
have to start doing that you hate doing
that you've had to start doing in the
past in either of those scenarios in all
of those scenarios you're learning more
about the customer you're learning about
their dreams and aspirations but the
pains that they've experienced along the
way and the culmination of all of those
answers become how part one and how part
two the good stuff you're going to help
them get and the bad stuff you're going
to help them avoid and if you're still
wondering how am I going to make money
from all this stuff don't worry we're
going to get there right now step five
putting it all together combine so this
is the Mr Miyagi moment in Karate Kid
where you've been waxing on and waxing
off this entire time so you can get to
the moment where you can finally get
your car so we're going to do osim money
Mad Lib we're going to drop everything
in so I help who which we got from step
two which is the combination of what the
big thing's about and then narrowing it
down through step one and step two I
help who 35-year-old male accountants
get a new income stream whatever the
whatever the good thing that they want
is Right which is how part one
without how part two the bad stuff
through and this is going to be the
bonus that I'm going to cover in a
second all right which is something
called a unique mechanism all right so
I'll cover that in a moment but
fundamentally you could ignore this last
part and this is the basic version of it
and this is the more advanced one once
you get some reps and the reason I'm
going to explain that one in a second is
because if you haven't done it yet you
don't have a unique process and so if
you're just starting out this is me
meeting you where you're at I help who
get good stuff without bad stuff I help
45-year-old women who just had kids get
into High School get back into their
High School jeans without giving up time
with their family I help non-fiction
business authors get on the Wall Street
Journal bestseller list without looking
cringe and listen it doesn't have to be
like you don't have to perfectly do this
every time I could just say I help young
guys starting school for the first time
pick their Community under 30 minutes
like it's just if you can nail them then
the person's like shoot that's me right
the more you add these pieces in they're
like that's exactly what I'm struggling
with this is exactly what I want and
then the unique mechanism makes it nice
and sexy so now that we hit the bonus
let's go to the bonus section so the
bonus number one is going to be
something called the unique mechanism
all right now the reason I wanted to
combine it before the unique mechanism
is that if you are starting out you
might not have a unique process yet all
right but a unique mechanism is
something that differentiates Your
solution from other peoples so if
there's two people in your Market or 10
or 100 people in your Market one you
could probably go narrower your Who and
the problem you're trying to help them
solve but let's assume that you did that
and there's still 10 people that all
help 35-year-old male accountants you
know uh watch Friends reruns because
that's your passion without feeling the
Judgment of other people because you
have a cool streaming platform or you
know access between all these other ones
that allow them to do it for free
whatever okay so let's say that that's
your Niche and there's 10 other people
who are serving them what you want to
have is some unique mechanism and this
is not a new Marketing Concept you want
to have some sexiness or some special
sauce that makes the prospect think oh
I'm going to push all of my hopes and
dreams into this process like if I had
only had this special sexy thing I was
six inches away from gold and then I
just needed this thing to get me over
the hump and the point is that that's
what they should feel like oh if I just
had had this thing all along I would
have already been successful so it's
like you have this secret that you can
help them be successful with and the
proof is in the pudding and so even if
you think about this YouTube video as a
product if you wanted to the unique
mechanism is the five-step process or
the five-step niche narrowing the niche
narrowing nunchuck right because it's a
a wax it on the head so let me
explain how this works is that you're
going to either have a list or steps
that someone has to follow to achieve a
result fundamentally that's what it is
you're either going to say you have to
do all these things so just think of
checklist like once you have done all
four of these things you'll achieve the
outcome or you have to follow this in
sequence you have to do one and then you
have to do two and then you have to do
three and then four the difference here
is that these don't have to be in order
you just have to do them all here you
have to do them in a specific sequence
but either way you're going to have a
list or a step a series of steps that
someone's going to follow and then all
you do is that you wrap this whole
thing and then you name it because this
becomes your proprietary process and
that proprietary process becomes your
unique mechanism if you've heard me talk
about content we have promise proof plan
and so it's hey I'm going to help you
pick your Niche by the end of this video
proof is that I've helped tens of
thousands of people do this on school so
are pretty good at it and then the plan
is we're going to follow these five
steps Tada and here we are and so that
process we can call the mosy money Niche
method whatever so if you've heard of
P90X the unique mechanism they had was
muscle confusion right and obviously a
zillion Fitness influencers like there's
no such thing as muscle confusion and
they're right but the thing is is it was
unique mechanism they sold hundreds and
hundreds and hundred hundreds of
millions of dollars of fitness programs
using it if you look at Weight Watchers
they have a point system the point
system is their unique mechanism if you
look at some of these other ones they
have their XYZ portion control thing
like they all have a unique mechanism
their way of doing it think of this as
the vehicle this is going to take them
from where they are to where they want
to go and you're the one who's piloting
this ship with them in the back seat or
they're piloting it with you in the back
seat with you as the guide the point is
is that that becomes the special sauce
and everybody should do this and that's
where you can have the naming
conventions I cover naming stuff in my
last chapter here on the offers book
where I either like something that
rhymes or I like alliteration if I can
if I can do it so as promised if you're
following this process then you got the
what which helped you narrow down the
who you followed the steps in that to
Niche down to figure out very
specifically who the Avatar was Someone
Like You someone you've helped before or
someone who's underserved we did the
good stuff we looked at the bad stuff we
put it all together into one sentence so
you can immediately use it if you're a
little more advanced then you figured
out your unique mechanism or your system
or your process or your method to put it
all together so they're like wow this is
exactly what I need so what's this last
bonus well I said I'd help you get your
first five customers so let's do that
all right so I'm going to give you the
absolute simplest system for getting
your first five customers using what we
just had and so what you do is you will
greet someone greetings hello you will
mention something specific about them
that's a compliment you'll insert that
sentence that we just went up with came
up with and then you'll ask them if they
know anybody who could benefit from that
and you will do this for 4
hours per day or until you reach a 100 I
don't care which you can do four hours a
day or until you reach a 100 and if you
do this every day and you make this
process what you reach out to people you
will get five customers I outline this
entire process inside of the leads book
in the first chapter called warm
Outreach to help you get your first five
customers and if you like me to help you
lead along and you want to do it via
community you can go to school.com games
I walk people I literally walk thousands
of people through this every single
month uh so we're pretty good at it like
I said more than one out of two people
make their first dollar online so um
check it out